Visit ListenLively.com
PETE: WELCOME BACK WELL NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO FACING
SCRUTINY AS HE SHOULD AFTER
FINALLY REVERSING COURSE FOR
COVID-19 PATIENTS IN NURSING
HOMES.
THIS COMES AS FLORIDA GOVERNOR
RON DESANTIS TOUTS HIS EARLY
ACTION TO PROTECT THE ELDERLY.
>> YOU’RE FOCUSING THOSE
EFFORTS WHERE THE THREAT
REALLY EXISTS, WHICH IS AT OUR
SENIOR POPULATION, SO WE DID
VERY EARLY WITH THE NURSING
HOMES, WE RESTRICTED VISITATION
AND WE PREVENTED HOSPITALS FROM
DISCHARGING COVID-POSITIVE
PATIENTS BACK INTO NURSING HOMES
THAT’S LIKE A TINDER BOX IF YOU
LET THAT HAPPEN.
PETE: SOUNDS LIKE COMMON SENSE
TO ME NOT NEW YORK.
OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS THAT
DRASTICALLY DIFFERENT APPROACHES
OFFER LIFE AND DEATH
CONSEQUENCES.
CHECK OUT HIS NEW PIECE AT FOX
NEWS OPINION, HERE TO EXPLAIN
FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR DEROY MURDOCK.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THE MEDIA HELD UP CUOMO AS THE
EXAMPLE OF
LEADERSHIP IN THIS MOMENT BUT
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
TWO STATES AND THE ELDERLY
POPULATION IT’S A MASSIVE
CONTRAST.
>> IT’S A HUGE, HUGE DIFFERENCE
AND A VERY SAD DIFFERENCE.
HERE IN NEW YORK STATE, A
BRILLIANT IDEA ON MARCH 25 TO
TELL NURSING HOME PATIENTS YOU
MUST TAKE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COVID-19 POSITIVE AND PEOPLE WHO
HAVE GONE TO THE HOSPITAL AND
BECAME DISCHARGED ONCE THEY
BECAME MEDICALLY DISABLED THEY
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO SEND THEM
AWAY IN FACT NOT REQUIRED TO
TEST IT AND AS A RESULT WHILE
THE FOLKS GET BACK TO THE
NURSING HOMES PEOPLE GOT SICK
NURSING HOMES WHICH SHOULD NOT
BE TOUCHED BY COVID-19 SUDDENLY
BECAME HOT BEDS OF COVID-19 AND
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF SENIORS
STARTED DYING IN HUGE NUMBERS
AND THE DEATH TOLL IS LIKE 5,300
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
PETE: AND DEROY AS WE KNOW
THERE’S A VERY LARGE SENIOR
POPULATION IN FLORIDA.
IF ANYONE WOULD HAVE HAD THE
POSSIBILITY FOR A BREAKOUT
LIKE THAT THEY TOOK THE
EXACT OPPOSITE APPROACH
SAYING WE KNOW WHO IS MOST
AFFECTED BY THIS LET’S
PROTECT THEM.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT AND THEY SENT
TEAMS INTO INSPECT THESE NURSING
HOMES, THEY SENT PEOPLE INTO
MAKE SURE THE NURSING HOMES HAVE
ALL OF THE EQUIPMENT THEY NEEDED
THEY GAVE THEM ADDITIONAL
TRAINING ON HOW TO AVOID
INFECTIONS, AND THE RESULT SO
FAR HAS BEEN ABOUT 665 FOLKS,
SENIORS DEAD IN NURSING HOMES IN
FLORIDA.
THE DEATH RATE IN FLORIDA IS
ABOUT 3 HER 100,000 AND IN NEW
YORK STATE IT’S 27.5 PER 100,000
SO NINE TIMES WORSE.
PETE: WILL WE SEE THE MEDIA EVER
REALLY EXPOSE THIS CONTRAST THAT
CUOMO FINALLY REVERSED
COURSE AFTER DEFENDING PUTTING
COVID INTO NURSING HOMES WILL
THEY EVER HOLD HIM TO ACCOUNT
FOR THAT?
>> THEY REALLY SHOULD AND ONE
THING IS ALL OF THE OTHER
HOSPITALS WERE FULL BUT WE HAVE
THE JAVITS CENTER ONE-THIRD
EMPTY, THE COMFORT THE SHIP THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SETUP HERE WITH
182 BEDS FILLED OUT OF A
THOUSAND SO NOT LIKE THERE WERE
ALTERNATIVES TO SEND PEOPLE
WHERE THEY COULD GO AND BE
ISOLATED TO NOT GET HEALTHY
SENIORS INFECTED AND ULTIMATELY
KILLED.
HE NEEDS TO BE HELD TO ACCOUNT
ON THIS AND I WISH THE MEDIA
WOULD DO IT.
I’M HEARING A LITTLE BIT OF
CRITICISM IN NEW YORK.
PETE: THAT’S TRUE, WELL,DEROY,